okay so I'm getting this uh image of
your life but you're also very
enterprising you've been in movies uh
you've been in television uh you're
always on the go you're always flula is
slowly but surely taking over the world
yes well as a German that's illegal and
I would never admit to this I taking
what I meant I didn't mean to imply
anything I'm saying you are invading you
are yeah you are invading media with
your you you are uh I'm I'm subtly
Gathering stamps on my passport fully
legally and with everyone's consent you
are Blitz cing Hollywood with your
talent nope I am just very subtly
showing up with a cake and a smile a
massive air show of tal no no no no you
are daintily prancing
around now I had the pleasure of going
to Berlin with you remember when we were
in Berlin together I remember this yes
and this was fascinating for me because
I got to see you in your home
environment and I noticed that a lot of
the German people are very comfortable
with nudity oh very much and you seemed
very comfortable with nudity too I'm
also German so I am part of this V
diagram you have just described now I as
for example not comfortable with my
nudity at any time you did not enjoy
having your penis Exposed on the beach
no no I wear a full-on uh Formal Tuxedo
when I take a shower but you you on the
other hand um I noticed very comfortable
with it have you tried that here in the
states and and what's the reaction Ben
oh exposing my genitalia in just walking
yeah I don't mean just genitalia but I
mean letting your body be free of all
clothing have you been nude in America
and how has that gone over for you it
has gone in awkward ways I try to have
you seen the show Austin Powers and the
murder mystery man or I don't know the
name International murder international
Man of Mystery yeah in the beginnings it
is the credits he's always like turning
around oh maybe we will see his pee PE
but no it's a broccoli and then he turns
around and he's like what is that oh
it's a it's an M1 Abrams tank or
something and so this is how I try to
present it to myself in America because
I know everyone is terrified of nudity
here okay well I don't know if they're
terrified of it but it can be
inappropriate quickly I'm told you
bordered an American Airlines flight
completely nude that's the kind of thing
that's not cool I was wearing flip-flops
so
okay so that's inacurate okay well the
the news accounts I read did not mention
the flipflops well you didn't read deep
enough or they are terrible reporters
okay well this was the New York Times
And The Wall Street Journal these are
fine papers Nicholas Kristoff okay yeah
okay he apparently was sitting in the
row opposite you yeah well we are no
longer on speaking terms
so you were friends until you boarded
his until I just heard this news of my
flip-flops being omitted um so uh in
general you're doing well life is good
oh I absolutely terrible Conan um why
well the world is on fire people always
say that really mathematically no one
that is now alive will be alive in 222
years oh my God I didn't realize that
now just think about this I made all
these plans I know so now you have to
execute those plans immediately do it
all tomorrow you know don't wait what
they say wait tomorrow and it's too late
for today to make it so you should have
it you should do it
now I can't believe that hasn't been a
poster I think Benjamin Franklin no yeah
Benjamin Franklin as he was stroking out
said that don't put to tomorrow what
today can be done the other day you if
you go forward another day and then
please relight my stove and there's some
lightning there's a storm coming someone
put tie a key to a tie a key and make me
an omelet let me ask you something how
familiar are you with American history
are you are you do you consider yourself
I mean you've come to this country we
welcome you with open arms as America
does um sometimes but do you consider
yourself uh an American citizen now do
you think you're comfortable in these
ways I am very confused every time about
everything but I'm also very excited I
love to learn I'm like a spou you can
just dump things into me col you don't
dump things into a sponge a sponge sort
of goes over the it's it's an inaccurate
metaphor yeah and you added a u to the
spou just now I'm sorry go oh see Jesus
I took your you and added it to spou so
I'm Gorly again okay it's gorle and spou
all right okay so a wonderful tag team
detective show yeah they took the U from
gor and added it to sponge so it's Gorly
and spou better
than you uh whenever I'm done speaking
to you I'm very stupid at the end also
also and you don't so you don't get
smart
I'm speaking to myself never no no to me
when I'm done speaking to you I'm very
dumb always I'm going to go home I'll
probably have to be driven home because
I'm not safe to drive after speaking to
you CU I'm so stupid yes I I get it so
uh con when other people speak to me
it's like you know people like oh you
should have your teapot open and ready
to receive more tea but I have the top
the top is on what so if you put I don't
understand at all imagine a submarine
yeah how do we get to a submarine
imagine how many liquids and Waters and
airs enter a sub submarine that is my
brain when we speak okay very good I'm
going to change the topic okay to the
topic I was trying to talk about which
is you and America what about this
country confuses you uh a lot of there
there's much driving not much do you
have a burp is that a fart I just burped
oh okay I just quietly burped I'm
drinking a lot of water and I just
burped into the little microphone but
you also leaned up a bit so I didn't I
wanted you to I wanted you to see that I
was burping but the so that was purely
burped that was not a toot burp I can't
do the both at the same
I me thatd be in the almanac if I could
do that it's a flurp yes what's that a
FL and a blurp okay now I'm so stupid my
heart's not beating you've just taken me
down to Baseline activities that are uh
that are run by the cortex are gone yes
you're in the seventh level of the
Titanic you're just shoveling that coal
but no no Cuisines are being cooked you
uh do you like America it is very
enjoyable to me I feel very lucky I have
received a career thanks uh to you and
also other Americans who have have
employed me so feel D and thank you
Conan uh Christopher is it correct
O'Brien Conan Christopher obrien very
good that is my name Googled you yes oh
you have yes yeah you are a comedian and
also a
host a host yeah do you also say ghost
yeah ghost ghost and host ghost yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah gist is like your
spirits so
okay guys guys guys I feel like I'm the
odd man out at the UN what's going on
here we were saying can we talk so that
you can't understand oh very nice well
that's really that's some real
Hospitality there sorry Bangladesh yes
now how much how much uh German do you
speak well I'm joining
in uh
globin okay if you're going to make
stupid off refences rude leard okay well
that's just nonsense do you mind do you
mind if I go back to speaking real
German yeah have a real conversation
yes
break the
BMW
so that's how it's done gor the next
time you
feel no incorrect no no longer speaking
German no oh oh
of
yeah and clink oh mashing
Mash you know what I don't think we can
even I don't think we can put ads on
this episode because no one's listening
no no I think we have to contact all the
advertisers and say you don't want to
waste your money on this episode cuz
absolutely nothing is
happening